I have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine to david p you can call the
number absolutely any time of day that
you want to leave me a voicemail not all
voicemails that are left on this number
are very nice some people in our
audience might know that here's one such
example you're an absolute piece of crap
you don't know what you're talking about
your stupid kids probably know served in
the military right Trump is only one the
greatest presidents of all time you are
a delicious pinko commie and you've been
brainwashed by the 88 obama ascension
you're just eventually you guys are
gonna see what the hell's going on and
going to be too late yeah you know get
off the air what somebody real get on
your whole TV stations a bunch of pink
you call me leftist yeah I hate to break
it to you but if your critique of me is
that I never served in the military and
that that's an objective critique that
makes someone unqualified to I don't
know do whatever you realize the guy you
think is going to be the great president
that is going to be the commander in
chief of the military President Donald
also didn't serve in the military and by
the way not under the most upstanding
circumstances it's a effectively opting
not to uh serve in the military so it's
weird to critique me for not having
served in the military but then to
cheerlead a guy who hasn't served in the
military and will actually be making
military decisions I'm not going to be
making any decisions for the US military
Donald is and this guy seems to level
yeah I mean there's a lot of
questionable things to point out from
that voicemail and yeah I don't I don't
know where this guy was going with this
for the most part no it's uh yeah I mean
listen I present to you with only
minimal comment and you can make of it
what you will we have such a great bonus
show today India's Prime Minister is
urging the country to continue moving in
a cashless direction and we're going to
talk about the idea of cash versus
electronic payments risk rewards good
things bad things and a lot more on
today's bonus show there's also a very
interesting article in the Atlantic
about why middle-class Americans are
increasingly unable to afford to live
in those great big blue liberal cities
around the country and i also want to
present to you an idea that has been
increasingly mentioned in some economic
circles over the last few months that
long periods of stability by their very
nature cause instability so it gonna be
a really interesting bonus show today
remember that the 2017 david pakman show
calendars continue to be available
autographed or not autographed your
choice at david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 if you want one of these for
free you can also get it with a yearly
membership at david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 and if calendars aren't your
thing and you want to support the show
but the regular membership prices are a
little high that's okay i want everybody
involved i don't want price to be a
barrier to people you can use coupon
code i voted 17 all one word all lower
case at david pakman.com slash
membership save some money on those
memberships a buy-in at any level is
what we're looking for speak to you on
the bonus show